-Welcome back.
I'm here with Rosario Dawson.
And we're about to play a game
called "Know Your Better Half."
But to do that, we're going
to need your better half.
So please welcome former mayor
of Newark and current
senator from New Jersey,
Cory Booker!
-Hello. Hello.
She is definitely the better
half in this relationship.
-I know. Okay, good.
Alright,
here's how the game works.
One of you will wear
noise-canceling headphones
while the other answers
a question about you.
Then you will take off
the headphones,
and we'll see if your
answer matches.
Make sense?
-Makes sense.
-Here we go.
Rosario, the first question
is about you,
so please put on your headphones
and play some music really loud.
Give me a thumbs-up
when you're ready.
[ Laughs ]
I feel like it's working.
Okay, here we go.
Cory, here's the question.
You both follow a vegan diet.
If Rosario ever had
a cheat meal, what would it be?
-I think that the one food
that she goes crazy over --
And we have a big fight
over this,
because she's from New York,
I'm from New Jersey.
Jersey obviously has
the best pizza,
New York, the second-best
pizza in America.
So I'm going to, unfortunately,
have to enter into
this debate publicly with her.
But I'm going to say pizza.
-Oh, my gosh.
Okay, this is unbelievable.
Alright, alright.
-Oh.
♪ I just can't be polite ♪
♪ Don't worry about me ♪
-The question was,
"You both follow a vegan diet.
If Rosario ever had
a cheat meal,
what would it be?"
-I mean, I'm a New Yorker,
so I'm always going to have,
like, pizza, bagel and lox,
you know --
-The best pizza in the world,
New York pizza.
-Yeah. You got to be able
to get a slice.
-Honey, honey...
-You know, it's great to have a
normal, regular vegan pizza,
but, like --
-Honey,
you know the best pizza --
Now that you live in New Jersey,
the best pizza in America
is Jersey pizza.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
Just don't do anything.
Just bite your tongue.
-What? I'm sorry. What?
-You cut out.
The Zoom cut out. Very good.
Cory, it's your turn
to put on the headphones.
-I'm going with
"Seasons of Love" right here.
-Oh. Okay, here we go.
Here is the question.
You two recently
moved in together.
What's Cory's
weirdest habit at home?
-He would probably say,
because he just started doing,
you know, like, Wim Hof Method,
like, cold stuff,
so he's been doing
these cold showers.
-Okay, here we go.
-Am I good to come back?
-Yeah, you're good. Yeah.
Okay, the question was, "You two
recently moved in together.
What's Cory's weirdest
habit at home?"
-So, a big issue has come up
recently in the relationship
because I now, most mornings,
will take contrast showers,
where you stand
under ice-cold water,
but it has
a lot of health benefits.
-That is a match.
That is exactly what she said.
She said the cold showers.
Dude, you guys are crushing it.
Alright, you're 2 for 2 here.
Cory, please put
the headphones on again.
Alright, Rosario,
this is the last question.
What was Cory's smoothest move
when you were first dating?
-I don't know that I
would call Cory smooth per se.
That's not why we're together.
I find him very punny and clever
and passionate and wonderful.
He, all for an entire year --
Especially
when he was campaigning
and I was taking care of my dad
and we were apart a lot,
he would wake me up every day
with a song.
So he would send me a song.
So we have this playlist,
and, you know,
there's almost 200 songs.
But it just would initiate
a conversation every morning,
and then we would talk about
the song and what it meant
to either of us,
or if it was a new song --
It was just -- It was wonderful.
Now we have a love playlist,
which is great.
-Oh, my gosh.
Everyone is freaking out
right now, going,
"Honey, why don't we have
a love playlist?"
Oh, my God. That is amazing.
Alright, I can't wait to --
I want to see
his reaction to this.
The question was,
"What was Cory's smoothest move
when you guys were dating?",
when you were first dating.
-[ Laughs ]
That is an awful question.
I'm sorry, because I'm not
the smoothest.
I'm not the smoothest.
So, I don't know if
she would --
She probably just said
I'm not smooth,
but I will tell you,
I think I do things
that are sweet at least.
-Alright, not only are you
in such big trouble
because, dude, she actually
said, "He's not smooth,"
which is what you said,
so you get points for that,
which is unbelievable.
You guys are, like,
perfect together. But --
-But hold on.
What did she say, though?
She had to have said something.
I'm curious.
-How about the love playlist?
-Oh, okay, yeah.
So, when we first --
-Now you know about it.
-He's good.
-Now it's your favorite thing.
-I find that clever.
-Yeah, of course.
Thank you so much
for playing this.
That is
"Know Your Better Half."
You guys crushed it.
My thanks again to Senator
Cory Booker and Rosario Dawson.
"Go-Big Show" is on Thursdays
at 9:00 p.m. on TBS.